this week on brian ross investigates
the hacker crime wave hospitals police
stations
power grids oil fields and now the
pipeline
that carries gasoline to a quarter of
the country setting off
consumer panic huge lines formed across
multiple states yesterday
as panicked americans started to run on
gas
colonial pipeline reportedly paid a 5
million
ransom to a criminal group to get back
access to its computer system
and restore operations america's former
cyber czar says
that was wrong i don't think we can make
exceptions i think we have to make it
illegal
for anyone to pay these ransoms and as
soon as we do that
they will go away plus the masks are
coming off
even as huge numbers of americans many
christian evangelicals
refuse to get vaccinated we're joined by
an evangelical minister
to explain why evangelicals have trained
themselves
and been trained to be very suspicious
of two things
one is the government the other
unfortunately is science
plus this week's winners and losers in
the media
was chosen by the editors of meteorites
see if you agree
this puts us in a position to be the
number one news global news force
in the world from the law and crime
trial network
this is brian ross investments
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined as always by my
colleague rhonda schwartz
and ronda we begin with what has to be
called a 21st century crime wave
tech savvy hackers taking hostage
kidnapping really the computer systems
of hospitals
police stations even the power grid and
now one of the country's most
vital pipelines the colonial pipeline
which said it had no choice but to pay
a 5 million ransom rhonda
that's right brian and the impact was
quickly felt by its customers as long
lines formed to gas stations
but the bigger broader question even
more troubling who will be the next
victim of ransomware president biden
promised
a strong law enforcement reaction
we're also going to pursue a measure to
disrupt their ability to operate
and our justice department has launched
a new task force
dedicated to prosecuting ransomware
hackers
to the full extent of the law we're
joined now by richard clark the
country's farmer cyber czar who knows
everything there is to know about cyber
terror
mr clark thank you for being here you
have warned about this exact thing for
years
it happened is it going to happen again
well brian it will continue to happen as
long as you can make money on it
and that's why i've been advocating that
we make it illegal
to pay the ransoms uh if they're not
getting paid
they won't do the attacks now the
criticism i've taken
for this proposal is that there are some
things that need to be restored
instantly
like hospitals uh and that hospitals
should
be allowed and other things should be
allowed to be exempt
and to be able to pay the ransoms uh i
don't think that's a great idea i think
what instead we should have
is a public private partnership task
force
that when the hospital is hit swoops in
and gets their essential services back
online quickly i don't think we can make
exceptions i think we have to make it
illegal
for anyone to pay these ransoms and as
soon as we do that
they will go away in the case of
colonial they reportedly paid some five
million dollars
what was it they feared would happen
that the hackers would somehow blow up
the pipeline
well i i don't think the hackers
threatened that although they
clearly were in the system so they could
probably
have affected the controls the problem
that colonial had was it
didn't know what was in the pipeline at
what
section of the pipeline uh they didn't
know who they were going to bill
for it they couldn't get paid for it uh
so there was a
uh there was a monetary interest that
drove a lot of what colonial did
in addition to which they wanted to get
online as soon as they could
they were under pressure from the white
house to get back
online and start pumping again but if
they had
appropriate backup systems they could
have just
brought down the backup mounted that and
got running again
now the people who get hacked get hacked
because it's possible to hack them
their security is bad and the same
people who have bad security
have bad backups and so most of the time
they need to pay so they can get back
online quickly
these companies often have insurance for
this very thing
so insurance companies are making the
payments insurance companies are
a big part of the problem brian because
if you have cyber insurance and you call
them up and say
whoops i've been hacked they under the
table will tell you
off the record will tell you pay up
we'll give you the money
uh your insurance policy will cover it
and it's
cheaper for the insurance company to pay
up
than it is for the insurance company to
do the alternative which is to restore
your system
if you were in your own job at the white
house would you advise would you have
advised colonial not to pay and would
you have threatened
prosecution if they in fact did pay well
there's no basis now
uh to prosecute them what i would do if
i were in my old job
is get the president to issue an
executive order making it illegal to pay
he can do that he has the power under
law to do that
number two i would create that task
force to rush in
and help people get back up online if
they are an essential service
and the third thing i would do would be
to command cyber command the military
to go find these guys on the internet
and destroy their networks which is also
something that's
in our power to do what i think the
biden administration did
was use back channel communications to
the russian government
through military channels through
intelligence channels law enforcement
and diplomatic channels
and told the russians i think this is a
reach too far
these guys are in your country shut them
down
and what has happened over the weekend
the
hackers say they're shutting down the
hackers say
this particular group of hackers say
we're not going to do it anymore
which suggests to me that they were
under pressure from the russians
and they'll probably come back a week
from now with a different name
the president said that the fbi the
department of justice will fully
investigate
is that uh for real can they really
investigate and find out who did this
well the justice department can't but
the intelligence agencies can
and what normally happens is someone
like the national security agency
uh will find out who did it and then
they'll slip the information to the fbi
and the fbi will announce it like it was
their discovery
so we've seen the pipeline shut down
power grids in other countries
hospitals police departments who's next
do you think in terms of
the targets these hackers may try to hit
well they're usually
two criteria that the hackers use one
will they be able to pay do they have
enough money or do they have insurance
and two is their security so bad uh that
we can get in
easily and they probably won't have a
backup system that they can switch to
in a way this is like darwinian uh
survival
it's the the survival of the fittest if
you're in
good shape if you have good cyber
security if you've paid for good
defenses
you're not going to be attacked the
people who are being attacked
hospitals police departments pipelines
they're people who really weren't paying
attention and really were not doing a
good job
on cyber security in my business it's
been a dirty little secret for years
that the pipeline companies are wide
open why
because there's no government regulation
of cyber security on pipelines
that's the difference why aren't banks
being hit
because the banks are being regulated by
the federal government as to their
insurance
as to their cyber security as to their
configuration
so banks don't get hit because they're
secure because the government makes them
be secure
and pipelines do get hit because the
government is not
yet making them be secure
all right richard clark country's former
cyber czar cyber terrorist thank you so
much for being with us
this evening thank you very much
coming up next good news on the covet 19
front
tempered by the fact that so many
americans including huge numbers
of christian evangelicals are still
refusing to get vaccinated
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the long crime trial network
there is good news at long last this
week on the covet 19 front
the masks are coming off with the
infection and the death rate falling
yet there remains one huge problems the
number of americans who are still
refusing to get vaccinated
many of them christian evangelicals so
we thought it'd be good to hear again
what was behind all this from a man
himself who was a christian evangelical
minister
we're joined now by reverend rob shank
an evangelical minister and president of
the dietrich bonhoeffer institute
in washington d.c reverend shank thank
you so much for joining us tonight
it's my pleasure let me ask you why are
so many evangelicals indicating
they won't take the covet 19 vaccine
well there's both a simple answer to
that and a very
complicated one i'll spare you the
latter
and go to the more simple explanation
and that is that evangelicals have
trained themselves
and been trained to be very suspicious
of two things
one is the government the other
unfortunately is science uh
and both of them come together in the
vaccine
uh now complicating even that
is uh the political atmosphere
because american evangelicals
particularly white
american evangelicals are
have been highly politicized there are
times when it's hard
to tell an evangelical from
a hard right political conservative
and vice versa so you put all those
things together
and you get a perfect storm of
opposition
we've seen some evangelical ministers
raise the question of
the mark of the beast covet 19 vaccine
versus triple six is this the mark of
the beast
should i be vaccinated should you be
vaccinated should you be crying for the
vaccine
what is meant by that what's the fear
well again this goes back to
[Music]
a certain interpretation of a series of
passages
in the new testament particularly in the
book of revelation the
the final book in the new testament that
speaks to many
of the future and in the future there
will be
this world government
run by a global dictator
who will among other things persecute
what we would term bible believing
christians
and one of the ways he will persecute
my community in this interpretation is
that
uh we will refuse to take
the mark of the beast this symbol of
allegiance or devotion uh to the
dictator
and lately it's become the idea that it
might be
a microchip you know that's
inside the formula of a vaccine
uh you're pressured or maybe even
ordered by government
to submit to taking the vaccine
therefore you are forced
to become a devotee of this false
prophet and a world dictator
so you know this becomes a kind of
fantastical conspiracy that's really
quite modern
what do you say to them well a couple of
things
uh one is i remind them that it's god
who speaks to us through the prophet
isaiah and says
come let us reason together says the
lord
he invites us to engage uh
with him
reasonably that reason is an
attribute of god so this kind of
fear this inordinate
uninformed
almost paranoia is not reasonable
reverend shank one of the other
arguments put forward by some
evangelical leaders and it's totally
false as best i know
is that the vaccines based on fetal
tissue
it is incumbent upon the body of christ
to step up and speak out against the use
of our tax dollars
to create anything made from aborted
fetal tissue
and that is raised a lot uh in my
community
um you know if you look
at the data and again
uh the science and inform yourself
you'll see that's not true
of uh you know some of the formulations
there are distant connections but again
this gets into
a question of christian ethics
and uh the question of the greater good
so if there is a way for us even if you
consider abortion
uh evil or a bad thing it is happening
it is occurring and the net result of
that
can be turning what we consider to be
uh something uh
you know deleterious or
uh immoral you can turn that to
something good
reverend shank when you challenge some
of these uh theories these uh
beliefs uh you get uh a blowback
from uh evangelicals your fellow
evangelicals
oh i've been called a heretic uh
i've been told that i've been uh turned
into an instrument of satan
i've been threatened physically
but again you know here i sound like the
preacher i'm sorry but i am
jesus said rejoice when
people speak ill of you
because they're really
going after me because you represent me
as an evangelical
my job is to represent christ not myself
and he said we're to take care of our
neighbors
let me ask you finally what would it
take to persuade uh the evangelicals who
have been so
resistant to the vaccine is there are
are they can they be persuaded what
would it take
well you know i wrote a memoir about my
own journey from the hard
christian religious right uh to the
place i am now which i think is much
closer
to the message that jesus came both to
proclaim and to model for us
and uh i called it costly grace and
evangelical ministers rediscovery of
faith
hope and love so i take people back
to what is the most loving thing we can
do for
our family our friends
our fellow church members the
communities we live in
well it's very simply this we can help
save their lives by
stopping this virus at ourselves
and one way you can do that is by being
vaccinated
because you've stopped the progress of
the virus
and its mutations that are so
threatening to your neighbors
and to those you love to your parents
your
aging parents uh to your own
uh close loved ones maybe to your pastor
who may be older there's all kinds of
ways you practice love and one way
uh is to stop this virus in its tracks
reverend rob shank thank you so much for
being with us here on the law and crime
network thank you
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media what's going on at
jeopardy
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the long crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of meteorite and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin who's the
editor-in-chief of mediaite
which like the law and crime trial
number is part of the dan abrams
media company nathan we begin with the
winner a new media company given birth
today
to take on both netflix and disney plus
it doesn't have a name but it has a boss
david zasloff who until recently was the
head of the discovery network which
he'll now run along with the media enter
the media properties from at t here's
how he put it today
everyone wakes up every day and they
want to know they want to know what the
news is what's going on in their
community what's going on in politics
and so this is right up the sweet spot i
think for us and it makes us
really unique this puts us in a position
to be the number one
news global news force in the world
so zesloff is going to be a very
powerful figure in the media world
controlling both cnn hbo plus his own
discovery network aiden
that's right so i'm just going to give
you a little bit of the background here
uh to give you an idea of how this came
to be and how david
came to control this new media company
uh which is
as you say going to be incredibly
powerful now at t
decided to get into the content game
about three years ago
uh and they bought time warner for an
enormous amount of money
that allowed them to acquire cnn hbo
warner brothers under this media
property that they called warner media
now three years later a t is selling off
that media company
they no longer clearly no longer think
that it is valuable to them
um and they're spitting it off and it's
being now merged with discovery which is
run by david zasloff
um that leaves cnn in a really
interesting spot obviously that
is our focus at mediai is what the fate
of cnn is going to be now
jeff zucker who is currently the
president of cnn had said that he was
going to step down at the end of this
year
uh now that cnn and warner media is
being merged with discovery
to make this much bigger new uh company
which is probably going to have a lot
more of an interesting power dynamic
than just uh warner media and cnn did
before
uh that could be enticing to jeff sucker
to say and in fact there were a lot of
reports today
hinting that you might be staying on
with cnn and with this new company in a
broader capacity
but ultimately we do know that it's
going to be run by david zapslav
who is an executive who's been running
discovery for some years uh so he was
our winner for the day
he'll be a powerful figure as the
consolidation in the industry continues
now to the loser what in the world's
going on at jeopardy take a look at this
clip of one of the contestants
and our returning champion a bank
examiner from winthrop massachusetts
kelly donahue
so that one gesture with the three
fingers what did that supposedly mean
aidan
so i think you and i would probably see
that and think okay he's flashing a
three
why why would a jeopardy contestant be
flashing a three as it turned out
it was his third win uh in jeopardy and
when he won his first game he flashed
one on his second game he flashed at two
and uh that contestant his name is kelly
donahue they're asked to flash to three
on his third win
uh but for some reason a legion
hundreds of former jeopardy contestants
did not
reach that conclusion uh despite being
all very smart people
uh and having appeared on jeopardy they
thought that he was flashing a white
power
symbol um one contestant uh
was it a white power symbol it was not
he was watching the number three
uh i'm not sure where they got that from
but they spun up a
masked conspiracy about it and there was
a lot of outrage
fortunately it was not true
all right aidan mclaughlin thank you so
much for being here and thanks to all of
you for watching us
thanks to our great team at law and
crime for getting us on the air and off
the air
every week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you